finally the day of reckoning had come
Robert Baratheon marched on the city
after his victory at trident but my
father got there first with the entire
Lannister army at his back promising to
defend the city against the rebels but I
knew my father better than that he was
never one to choose the losing side I
told the Mad King that much I urged him
to surrender peacefully but he didn't
listen to me and he didn't listen to
Varys who tried to warn him but he did
listen to grand maester pycelle that
grey sunken you can trust the
Lannisters he said the Lannisters have
always been friends of the crown so we
opened the gates and my father sacked
the city
once again I came to the king I pleaded
with him to surrender he told me to
bring him my father's head then he
turned to his Pyromancer and the more he
said banned them all in their homes and
the mall in their beds tell me if your
precious Renly had commanded you to kill
your father and then stand by as
thousands of men women and children
burned alive would you have done it
would you have kept your oath then first
I killed the Pyromancer and then as a
King turned to flee I drove my sword
into his back burn them all he kept
saying burn them all I don't think he
expected to die I think he meant to burn
with the rest of us and rise again
reborn a dragon to have turned his
enemies into ash and that's when I slit
his throat
to make sure that didn't happen and
that's when that stock found me